when I say higher fast fire faster
promote fastest promote comes in a lot
of different ways sometimes I promote
people mentally sometimes it's like I
send him an email response to something
that's a hey okay Gary values this you
can promote emotionally before you even
promote financially you hire someone
there are six weeks in within that first
month or two let them know I learned
this from my father in Reverse my father
was scared to talk to his employees
because he didn't want them to ask for a
raise it was his biggest fear he avoided
them like the black plague he just felt
like the only thing that was going to
happen was them saying can you give me
another dollar an hour and he didn't
want to do that and so you can do that
right now the how many employees yeah
how many of the 35 do you think are just
like critical you need to talk give them
all an hour 30 minutes